the killas border crossing for tens of
thousands this is the official way in
and out of Turkey from Syria but if
you're an Isis fighter Kilis is not an
option Abu Mustafa who doesn't want to
show his face or give his real name is a
Syrian people smuggler he says he's
helped hundreds of Isis fighters get
into Syria he's also brought militants
some of them injured back out maiara he
took us to the spot where the smuggling
happens he says several times a day it
didn't take long to see it in action the
car sped to the border and dropped off
six men carrying bags it then rushes off
and the men approached the fence we
can't tell if these are fighters or
Syrians without passports but there
illegally crossing into Syria moments
later more people appear at the border
this time the Turkish military police
turn up and chase one man along the
fence and the reward for taking such a
risk Abu Mustafa charges just 15 pounds
per Fighter Alpha rune master would let
us Ibaka man last time they caught three
people there were seven in total trying
to get across among them Turks and Arabs
but the three that got caught with
foreigners they spoke English and the
police took them away easy mile they
often cross of their families their
wives and children they tell us were
coming to fight an Islamic state and
live that some of them don't even know
where they're going they just say we're
going to the Islamic state and there are
plenty of them Abu Ahmed fought with
Isis for 10 months in Northwest Syria he
says he's now left the group and is in
hiding but that foreign fighters are
still joining Hawaii asylees fish it
they go to Syria to be martyred they say
their former lives are over and there is
no going back most of them rip up and
throw away their passports when they
arrive Abu Ahmed also thinks us-led
airstrikes against Isis is backfiring
bringing extreme
groups closer together though are
lighted holiday finess after the recent
air strikes more fighters are joining
Isis like the nusrah front I know some
of them who have joined you can't
destroy Isis it had no effect in Iraq
what's the solution only God knows the
effects of Syria's war spilling over
into Turkey are visible everywhere some
are making a living out of the situation
doing whatever they can to get by as the
war drags on and military campaign
intensifies dismantling this network
becomes increasingly difficult